what people don't realize is that going
into driveways
13 seasons in so much has been done
how do you up up the ante to make it
fresh and new
for a brand new season right so really
had a really big challenge um
do we succeed i don't know oh my gosh
2013. take a look around honey you got
some competition
where rupaul's drag race
new season brings in new year's day i
want to take a little look back
uh before we head into season 13 and run
down some of your
guys's favorite things from seasons past
what do you guys consider to be the
ultimate
lip-sync for your life moment in drag
race herstory
actually um sasha velour and the rose
petals is
probably one of the most iconic
lip sync for your life moment oh yeah
like i would pay money to be one of
those pedals
[Laughter]
now you would pay good money that
just story if there ever was one wow
just pedals everywhere
like just icon legend
star moment i think my favorite personal
favorite lip sync
from the show is from all stars it was
uh alyssa evers and tatiana
doing shut up and drive
[Music]
it's so iconic it's so exciting and
you know they both just devoured it that
moment where they go
in and out
[Music]
that lives rent free in my mind forever
and always
i would definitely say um la ganja
versus joslin fox
on season six to um
the stupid girls
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
that was brilliant and iconic and i
think about all the time for me it's
still
brooklyn and easy
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
i'm sorry that that was just epic that
was just
epic they were all just pulling out the
flips the kick squirrels it was like
circus soleil
and you know i don't do that but like
you know i love girls i can
and so i was i felt like i was at a
direct show you know i wanted to throw
my cash on a tv screen
evie oddly glory
with that like face mask a headpiece she
had on
did a backflip in a full gown like
what unheard of
[Music]
i feel like some of ours lip syncs this
season are some
very very iconic moments coming up as
well i mean very excited i agree
some of them i was full like i cannot
believe i'm witnessing this right now
i just met you and this is crazy what is
the drag race quote that sticks out to
you the the line from the show that
you'll
quote until the day you die um mama this
is garbage
mama this is garbage right here
i find myself quoting nicki minaj every
day of my
literal life saying hey hey you're
wearing makeup today
i hate hate hate your hair and makeup
today
that is so funny i love a geogun what
you're gonna do is not know it's not
really what you play your white shirt
what you wanna do is
what you want to do is not necessarily
what you're gonna do
bye versa for some reason the first
thing that popped in my mind was william
going
nurse nurse
i don't know why i just i love her and i
love that line
i have to go with look over there what
look over there where not today say in
not today satan do you remember when
leslie was judging and she said she
didn't already done had horses
because she came out as like a polo
player she didn't already have
horses
[Music]
i don't know i guess it's not iconic but
i've cackled
me and uh my house we used to laugh all
the time because
our favorite um drag race quote
it's not an iconic one it comes from the
season three reunion
from delta work specifically when all
the girls were hounding at the heathers
about being heathers and delta work
unapologetically goes did i read
absolutely then i talk absolutely
did i read absolutely did i talk
absolutely
and we know the audience are not hazards
even though they're sitting right here
in this necklace
we know our names aren't heather even
though they're right here on our necks
[Music]
delta work [ __ ] uh olivia what's your
what's your line i have i have
like i feel like there's so many out
there
there are so many great moments and i
think we're gonna make so many
more on season 13. i think you know drag
race let me take a deep breath
sink again what's happening